[Music]
welcome to education i'm kevin smith
i'm andy mcelford okay so you missed
right before we went we said something
really [ __ ] funny
it's funny to you maybe we'll see i'm
asking andy to
reenact the moment that it happened
well here's what happened kevin i would
kevin couldn't hear me yeah
and so he was like hey it's you it's got
to be you and then he's like wait a
second
then he pushes a button somewhere under
his desk and he's like oh there you are
it was me we're doing it with a single
push of a button
yes hold on i was able to let's let's
take them back even further
we're not in the same room we're
obviously uh for those watching
you could see but for those listening
the traditional way
to ingest imagine if this is what the
other side of your room looked like and
we were just faking it
yes like and you were on the other side
of the desk and
like what masterful art direction
um so we're recording via zoom today
and uh in doing so um i could uh
hear andy up until i plugged in jacked
in
if you will to use a [ __ ] technical
term from the world of
[ __ ] high tech podcasting ladies and
gentlemen
i don't want to alienate how you use
that preposition yeah
yeah it's that preposition instead of
off let me tell you something you
propositioned me in a dream you better
wake up and apologize andy
yeah you're just really not gonna listen
today are you what you said
in any event so uh
we're about to record and we couldn't
because i couldn't hear andy all of a
sudden
and then i was like what the [ __ ] and
then i realized i hadn't pressed the
button on the soundboard
and then suddenly i could hear andy at
that point
um was it you that said with the press
of a button yeah
no it was it was you i kept going i was
like with the press of a button
i'm not was i i said something like i'm
a modern day sorcerer
yes bring andy in like a modern day
sorcerer and i was like well i mean no
because
first you get the sorcerer got it wrong
in this case
and then i said that's how it always
goes in those saucer movies man like
with the buckets and the brooms they
always get it wrong at first and they
bust it right
no no and then i said well you look at
gandalf
it's not like he ever got it right as a
sorcerer because
while he has all this power he's just
using a sword and killing
why doesn't he i mean he's got a staff
there you go
there you go you needed that setup line
go anywhere without it and that's when i
kids right mind you andy got the staff a
lot quicker
that's when i rocked this amazing
rejoinder where i said
gandalf ain't got no staff he's got a
bunch of hobbits but they'd do his
bidding
yeah that was that was the and that was
it that was the thing we were going for
like kevin laughed wasn't that worth it
he said
wait a minute we better start the
podcast we can't do anything we can't be
funny
without recording it exactly i said why
would we ever bother saying anything's
not going to be recorded for posterity
i said we're leaving gold behind here
sheer gold
and now that i hear it out loud
perhaps pool's cold if you will what is
it iron pyrite
yeah [ __ ] you can't buy any of that
iron right
man it's [ __ ] terrible um all right
so we're already in the show
we can't help but be in the show already
yes we are this is education folks
and in the [ __ ] the world of
vegemication
we generally have structure
yes four corridors four chambers sci-fi
the y and the by
but this week we're going off the grid
yeah normally i mean it's part of the
sort of
patent-mic relationship that kevin and i
have which is i adore
a format i love scripted elements i
can't can't go on without being prepared
and yet kevin is chaos he is the
tempestuous
yang to my no he is the call i am the
calming yang to his tempest juicy in
i would argue that um you know
somebody who's just like uh the [ __ ]
jewish space
lasers they are chaotic i
that's true i'm more like a like a
oversized
mischievous imp well either way chaos
comes in many forms you
as our listeners and now these are
common shots
does it come in chocolate and strawberry
or just [ __ ] i didn't say flavors i
said forms
you know like the 1040 e and the w2
does it come like a form of a glass of
water
like shape of something that can't carry
a glass of water
you kids you can't get this right or it
was always like
form of if she was like shape of an
elephant he was like form of water
and then she sucked him up in her nose
and he was just like oh
no we're related but [ __ ] it takes
amazing form of a different fluid
sorry they're brother and sister she's
shooting it out and she's like out of
her trunk her elephant trunk and she's
like it's more
viscous than usual he's like no
it's not he's trying to
try to hide that [ __ ] um
all right listen and for all we know
they weren't related they were just from
the same [ __ ] planet you know what
i'm saying
they told us they told us they were
brother and sister because it was this
[ __ ]
70s and they didn't want to scare us
they were like look it's [ __ ] up
enough that we're telling them that
there are aliens and they walk amongst
us and they're welcomed amongst the
[ __ ] alphas in this world
but we gotta [ __ ] if we if we say like
they can
[ __ ] anything they want they'll go crazy
so we gotta say that these two are
brother and sister
so they the kids realize they'll never
[ __ ] because oh my god if those two [ __ ]
forget it
we're [ __ ] like they always had
little things that they would say like
they're like joe
bill hannah barbara guys
yeah no that sounds a little too intense
for a kid's show
[ __ ] you it can't always be huckleberry
[ __ ] hounds sometimes it's got to be
the real world
man and super friends is a [ __ ]
it's a parable about the abuse of
authority
about those who seek to take away your
rights
your choices we paint them as fools
clowns and masks
that's what we do i gotta share
something with you
so you're sharing anything with me not
at all finally i'm gonna open up i put
up a [ __ ] picture of me
on instagram you know told a little
story cute little story
about uh some [ __ ] anxious idiot
on runyon was like you know i was
wearing too messy he was like two
masters overkill
and you know i just shot back batman
wears a mask and the guy looked at me
like
the [ __ ] like what does that have to do
with anything looks bad man where's the
mask over here it's always on his mouth
he didn't say that but he could see it
on his face but my point was like you're
gonna send
[ __ ] shout your nonsensical opinion
at me i'm gonna shout some nonsensical
fact back at you
and it is a fact that [ __ ] batman
wears a mask so that's it
i put up that picture told that little
story wasn't like now listen to me
everybody wear masks or wear two masks
or anything like that in a moment
he's [ __ ] candid about like i do it
because i've had a heart attack i'm high
risk blah blah blah
blah that anxious little idiot really
stuck with you didn't he go read the
[ __ ]
there are more go read the comments like
there are so many people that are like
what are you [ __ ] some sort of idiot
like
you can't masks won't stop you from
getting it like
no wonder we're still in this [ __ ]
pandemic a year
later because people like some people
are just like man
[ __ ] science your science is wrong and
fouchy was a liar
like they i was up there so sick how
it's [ __ ] politicized man something
as simple as like wear a [ __ ] mask
and we'd be out of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
they ain't going through it in australia
you know what i'm saying periodically it
flares up and then they [ __ ] turn
around and beat the [ __ ] out of it no
maybe not australia
new zealand new zealand they're cracking
a [ __ ] code
australia well that's where the hobbits
are from that's right man to bring it
all [ __ ] back and [ __ ]
right out of staff and he's like i had
to fire the staff because they all had
[ __ ] covet
and then they weren't allowed back on
the new zealand the island
until they got cleaned because they got
a smart prime minister there
it's just irritating man like i didn't i
didn't ask like i wasn't soliciting
opinion nor was i lecturing some guy was
like
hey man don't let you know just we need
another lecture from somebody in
hollywood
and i'm like where was the lecture the
only lecture
was the guy going two masks is overkill
like i got lectured i i can't stand how
[ __ ] some people are andy
i really can't well the science tells us
that literally if everyone
everyone yes wore a mask for three weeks
and did not transmit the disease to
anyone else
then don't tell them it would no longer
be a problem oh my god
but god that's you know you can't change
everybody all you can do
is work on yourself make yourself better
and you know you and i have always been
on the right program sounds like a lot
of [ __ ] work
well you're on a rigorous program of
self-improvement as i understand
sometimes as our as are many of us
so point being well i'm saying like
shoot do for it but don't don't expect
everyone else
to do what you want do what you can but
i didn't i'm saying
you i'm saying no that's the way that
people should yeah you're talking to the
[ __ ]
who [ __ ] anxious dude who said
something to me you think he's listening
to the show you're crazy
he's gonna hear your lesson you know
who's hearing the lesson me has fallen
on deaf ears because i'm like i
know um
was he wearing a petticoat was it
petticoat dungeon yeah man
he was giving me some of that petticoat
unction and i was like oh
sorry it's been almost it was almost
three and a half minutes before i made a
pun so i had to
uh it was a fun pun man it took me back
to the days of [ __ ] black and white
tv and [ __ ]
when you couldn't well that was in color
oh in the beginning petticoat junction
was in black and white
oh i know it uh there's uncle joe he's a
moving kind of slow
and he's not the most egregious
stereotype on the show what was the
spin-off
he was spun off of um green acres green
acres oh so i might be wrong maybe
petticoat junction did balloon
bringing started color green acres
didn't i don't think it did
in black and white certainly certainly
we know that the beverly hillbillies the
mothership of the hillbilly uh
you know uh rural shows uh was started
in black and white um the audience is
like
oh man i [ __ ] hate when you guys
don't do the format because then you
just wound up talking about the
stupid-ass beverly hillbillies and [ __ ]
oh well we don't talk about the beverly
hillbillies enough ladies and gentlemen
so today
and it's all beverly hills still yeah
this episode
beverly hills billy's family the beverly
hillbillies that's what it was
the 90210 you better believe it
it's beverly hillbillies wall-to-wall in
edge vacation
edge my hillbillies hillbilly mcation
let's talk about miss jane hathaway and
her bird love bird watching love
oh my god [ __ ] andy's a modern day
jane hathaway
bird bothering [ __ ] it won't
leave those [ __ ] poor pigeons alone
okay hey buddy let me see you fly
what you know i didn't say the player of
white-tailed kites getting it on the
other day um
white-tailed kite is a kind of a hawk
and uh
i was up at the um you saw the malibu it
was just like
i looked around and then gave you a
[ __ ] thumbs up with the swings
right yeah i'm gonna leave us with that
image
that's what happened um and he pulled an
egg i was like
turned out they weren't [ __ ] just
practicing a magic trick
um let me ask you this andy
andy or let me tell the folks this andy
has taken
uh to bird bothering he likes to [ __ ]
go stare at them and and
[ __ ] unnerve them imagine you're a
bird and you're just like
i have command of the [ __ ] skies and
[ __ ] like that but every once in a while
yeah i gotta come back down to earth and
get some business done
[ __ ] like that so i'm gonna land but
like
nothing could ever [ __ ] take away
from me the fact that
i'm a god of the [ __ ] air and [ __ ]
then you land and all of a sudden you're
being [ __ ]
stared at and judged
so now listen i know that [ __ ] man
who's like you know
maintaining the morality of it is solid
because he's not getting up in your
[ __ ] grill
but meanwhile you're a bird you're like
i don't want you looking at what i'm
doing here is secret bird [ __ ]
and [ __ ] okay so the bird bother is
just like
oh i've collected it and [ __ ] waits
for the birds to [ __ ]
and then the bird has to take off and
[ __ ] like that then where's the bird
land
on a telephone wire or electric wire
what happens it gets electrocuted all
because the bird bother
couldn't be bothered to [ __ ] look
this [ __ ] up online
and he was like i gotta go see it in the
wild man [ __ ] because he did
some beautiful bird lost its life
that's well it's bird bothering a sport
sports kings kings of jerks we've four
covered about 45 million americans
identified as bird watchers what yes
it's true
but during covid made popular
straight i mean excellently
um one reason that it got very popular
especially in new york was that
remember the black birder the guy who
was harassed by karen who
called the cops on him yep yep now
there's like a
i think there's a people based off of
that story
people were like all i get out of that
story is that
bird watching sounds fun and they all
yeah
and so like there's a snowy owl and a uh
uh red tail hawk in central park right
now
and there are hundreds and hundreds
of people showing up for it it's like
more people show up for that than for
like press conferences for any famous
person it's
incredible and there's more cameras and
because people are really into it
it's exciting it's like a barrage of
bird bothers you know what they call a a
group of bird bothers
an andy of bird bother wow
here it's like andy are you making it
andy's not continually smart and he's a
very smart individual
he realizes that you give a [ __ ] upon it
yes
he he andy realizes that
his past pastime is creepy
and cucky and scary to a bird especially
so he wants to legitimize it you mean
yeah by turning it into a thing
really is that it so you're now
psychoanalyzing me i love how
do you like them what you want to turn
into or we're not supposed to spoil it
you just smash every passion that i have
until i don't care anymore
smash it and then you're happy and
you're happy you're like why would you
think of anything else besides
comic books and smoking weed and i'm
like i only think of one of those things
um are you gonna keep a secret what
you're gonna do with your
yes i am i am it's the one because i
don't want you to take a big crap on it
the one thing i will say kids
this is a smart idea it's a good idea i
thought i was very proud of andy
for his bird bothering if you're going
to bother the birds
this is the woody heaven is the bird
watcher bother
you are the bird watcher botherer i am
your job is to bother birds my jobs
bother you i'm like hey
hey what are you looking at that bird
for a bird and how's that job paying
pays and spiritual dividends you can't
even count
just like bird watching um
i think it's so awesome that you have a
hobby and it's so like
innocent and [ __ ] cute in a weird way
and
fitting as well you kind of you got you
got a bird
father look about you i like that last
uh
that last thing you just said because
you're like i'm not gonna look
way down on you i'm just gonna look
slightly down on you
i'm gonna modify my position to just
count my nose at you i like your thing
that you do it's cute
i haven't really listened in dead and
yeah
well the while the work you do is
excellent they call it a hobby
and just say how cute i think it is
oh that's awesome all right
um andy
loves them birds all right well i'll
explain why we're not going to have a
formatted show this week
i was getting to that right right andy
loves them birds so much
i just didn't want you to say anything
else it's really why i changed the
subject but he
forgot to write a show this week no that
has nothing to do with it he was so busy
with his
[ __ ] nose of some bird's cloak or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
at least at least i got that vocabulary
word into your brain
you know you're just like at least you
know what a bird butthole is called
that's what you do here on education
kids you learn [ __ ]
important [ __ ] like where birds what a
bird's proper hole is called
um what was the uh what was the [ __ ]
the oh thank god
no i'm not frozen you were frozen i can
hear you
i know but on the recording you were
frozen now you guys i get to get my
licks in
another eye roll that's why my eyes are
so surprised because i talk to you so
much and i rolled them
i thought it was because you had a mouth
full of millet is that what it's called
what's the [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not telling
you because you forgot
you were like that's my favorite thing
that's my favorite thing i'm going to
make t-shirts
and wait what's it called again i'm like
i tell you again you're like i'm going
to tell my wife about it
this is what i'm going to tell her and
then you're like what is that called
again
it was a week in seven days so i guess
it's called out
what's it called let's call it millet
why don't we right that was right
no you were not what's it called
so that i hear it's like hmm amount of
ammunition
hey can you hand me some ammunition like
sure it's called milk
so there you go here you go kevin it's
called melt
[ __ ] mush full of milk tucking baby
[ __ ]
um okay no i was i was thinking of the
i was cr i was mixing up the bird cloaka
and the
fish milt two things that don't happen
unless
a fish melted my bird chloe
two great tastes that go great together
reese's milk clow wake up
milk clo wake up butt
um all right enough about bird holes and
fish come this week
no proper episode man cause [ __ ]
sometimes we just like to cut loose
go well one of us does go off the grid
yeah well go [ __ ] off-roading and
[ __ ] like that i had [ __ ] to do
i should see you know i write off rodan
off
gamera off godzilla
off king kong off menya
off kingidora off because i said
off-road
then roden off rodin see what i did
there i [ __ ] escalated it through all
the
what they now call the titans but we
used to call them monsters
right right yeah when i'm not laughing
it doesn't mean i didn't get what you
were saying
hey man it's me kevin smith have you
been looking for all my old podcasts the
ones i started recording back in 2007.
well guess what i found them
they're all hiding in that kevin smith
club see all the video you've never seen
including exclusive movies and
live shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
if you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club now's your chance to
club
kevin smith uh sorry i'm so feisty today
but
why are you feisty well you know i've
been working a lot and busy and staying
up late and doing all those things
and one of the clients as you know
sometimes i will write
there's a few midlist comedians out
there that
have me write jokes for them and there's
a big meeting now i think you're going
to say one of the clients wanted to kiss
and that's not my policy
you couldn't make it through a whole
semester we had a pretty woman kind of
situation
on our hands but i was falling in love
because
if i'm not out at the plaza hooking my
little man [ __ ] i'm locked in this tiny
closet
that you can see
if you're listening to edumacation don't
forget you can always watch it
well if you're not listening to edge
medication you're like one of the two
people that is actually on it
tell them why we're not doing a smile
well i was trying to feed you
the pretext the pretense the fake
uh you know
building block of this yes of this
episode fair enough what is it
well that one of my clients has decided
the agents got together and they thought
you need to lean more into your oh
that's upbringing part of the [ __ ]
setup for the show yes you're just
getting this aren't you
i am i thought because i was like what
clients has this guy got
and then i was like jesus christ i'm
gonna
i'm gonna make fun of him for mouth
stuff and then i realized it was all
part of the setup after you told me of
course
yes yeah it's that it's that leap of
faith logic you made once i explained it
to you
you could tell we don't pre-game we just
[ __ ] dive in and
play the game we do pregame you just
forget that we forgave
i guess we pre-gamed a little bit all
right go ahead
i set her up set her up he set her up
set her up ready set her up set her up
like the rosenbergs
set her up and he said
they got set up right they didn't really
do what they did
julius and ethel rosenberg i know who
the rosenbergs are did they get set up
i don't have a definitive answer for you
was that right because she was a cop
they were
cause celeb but also uh many people
think they were guilty so
but they were certainly excoriated it
was the uh
what's his name roy cohn who made his
career on
as a just a dirty tricks bad guy
later to be completely
exposed and excoriated in the stage play
angels in america
yes oh yeah and then in the in the
movies
when he died yeah um
and the ghost of ethel rosenberg played
by
meryl streep miss mill street if you
can't think of who might have played
someone
just say meryl streep newcomer meryl
streep
yes um she's gonna go remember the
simpsons perfume ad for meryl streep
no earl streep versatility
that was her perfume yeah um
all right so wait tell them tell them
your setup dude [ __ ]
will i finally get to it is that what
you're saying yes absolutely
so the agents have meaning they want
this one guy who's been doing actually
pretty good we need we've played some of
this stuff on the show
and you know he did a lot of midwest
stuff but when he got back to his
hometown of gotham city he's
actually filling the house a little bit
so they've decided they want him to lean
into his
sort of story and upbringing in his
material
because they want to develop like a half
hour uh you know single camera for
netflix or something like that so
that's been the work this week is
getting um
kevin's like we'll see about that
disgusting this guy's lucky man a lot of
us can't [ __ ] find work this guy's
getting working [ __ ]
yeah but it's you know some of the
material is not great some of the other
writers have
contributed to and i'm not sure i would
actually do this on
on the show but you know that's just the
way it goes
you you write for somebody and then they
do their stuff and then either it goes
or it doesn't
and then you have to vamp while you're
well your podcasting partner
can't seem to find things on the uh
there we go now i can close messages
get out of there yes scandal and there
i see what i'm looking for i'm gonna
zoom it up to 100 200
because i'm not blowing you can hear
everything you're thinking oh no
they'll find out if i dialed it i'll
find out my stagecraft
um okay uh so what you're saying then
andy
if i follow you correctly
is that um
we have a guest we have footage or
something yeah no
yeah no okay we'll start over
hey i hear we got some stuff from that
guy that we sometimes play in the show
yeah yeah oh clip you mean we got a clip
yeah yeah
yeah we can put well i mean we're doing
a video version so it kind of falls
apart at that point
i know but they get to see behind the
curtain too oh good point
yeah absolutely and also people have
been asking they're like i
have the youtube version but i want the
podcast version because i normally
listen to you when i'm on my way to work
and so we don't have the audio up for i
guess the last one so we have to
remember to do that
that's true and so for those audio
people the illusion will be complete
that we actually are playing a tape
they'll see it and they'll still know
what goes on they're gonna see behind
the curtain man this is the wizard of oz
moment of this [ __ ] show
you clattering collection of
collegiateness this is me giving away my
magician's secret everybody's going to
know how it's done
they're going to be like oh man that's
it no i can do it
ancient magician secret huh
all right sounds like ladies and
gentlemen
that we've got uh a treat for
for you all yeah we got a clip
from this show's favorite comedian and
we're not we don't like this guy
because he bombs because he does hard
we like this guy because of his spirit
he keeps trying he won't be defined
by who everyone says he is in life and
he literally came from nothing he came
from less than nothing
yeah horrible horrible childhood from
darkness
and uh lifting then he had a brush with
the law if you will
[Music]
and uh himself up by his boost
bootstraps and his mask straps and
you know he's trying to make he's trying
to make a change and that change
begins with uh taking away the pain
that he inflicted i guess in his old
life
he was very hurtful and he says now he's
turned over a new leaf
and just wants to make people happy so
he's turned to
comedy putting smiles on faces instead
of scars
yeah he went from being down to being a
clown
and that's what the world needs more of
so
you're going to hear him now just again
fair warning
that's not good not good at all
but he's trying and that's the important
thing man because you know what happens
from not trying
nothing like i may not think this guy's
that good but there may be people out
there who like he's the next jerky boys
he's bill maher for christ's sakes he's
a modern day bill maher
so i think the material is better than
that well we'll see
we're going to find out because we got a
clip for you ladies and gentlemen um
this is the audio from uh
from the club we're gonna press play and
here we go you'll probably hear the
the uh the mc let us know
what's going on mcfresh yeah yeah mc
fresh himself
uh mcfishface and uh we press play
ladies and gentlemen well we press pause
did you notice the deep inhalation of
breath that that mc took before
he started emceeing like it was
like if i knew that mc i would say you
should go see a long [ __ ] specialist
my friend
why would he need to he can he's got the
lung capacity of a champion
olympic swimmer that's true you can draw
that much breath and how much breath can
you draw in
see see see yeah but the good thing
about having short breaths is i could do
it quicker than you
so there you go than me i thought you
were talking about the announcer on the
uh
him too two years ago birds of a [ __ ]
feather flocking together
i'm pressing play listen how deeply this
guy [ __ ] breathes and play
ladies and gentlemen welcome
to gotham cheers plus do you hear that
breathing right there just big [ __ ]
swallow of breath
kind of emcee is that gets out four
words and [ __ ]
it needs to breathe bunch of [ __ ] if
i was at that comedy club i want my
money back i'd say
yeah of all the things that happened in
the last 30 seconds i would say that was
the [ __ ]
and we press play it's
bane
and welcome felt rather rushed
i was expecting a little talk up of my
accomplishments and achievements
i centered a uh an audition tape
to ted talks and it was
about city planning something i know a
bit about
from my adventures on the other side of
the law
although i guess i'm not per se on the
opposite side of the law now
i'm different to the law i'm a comedian
it is my job to mark the law if that's
but required and let in other places
respect it
if that is what gets me yields a comedic
response
with that admired let's laugh
shall we okay hold on
let's pause yeah oh my god he's off to a
[ __ ] rocket start don't you like that
don't you love it when a comic explains
comedy yeah
i think that what he's doing he's kind
of starting to kind of reach into the
andy kaufman
of it all and really kind of to be the
meta comedian discussing his process
discussing the role of a comedian in the
world you know it's smart
smart stuff agreed and look as long as
this guy ain't jerking off in front of
people
he's a good comedian in my book you know
what i'm saying even good comedians do
that
i don't know if you read the papers all
right here we go we press play
i've come tonight armed with a fuselage
of comedic material
you will be bombarded with laughs
okay pause now didn't he say did he say
fuselage and not fuselade
so obviously maybe he's playing with us
he's i don't foster brooks of uh
i don't think of gotham city i don't
think he's doing
maloproperism comedy andy i think he's
just not
fully aware of the difference between
those two words but now
that was he question more than a
statement there you and i got it that's
the important part
i feel bad i'm giving him the benefit of
every doubt i feel bad for the people
who in the room who were like
did you hear that i did that's my point
are you recording
hi all right
and we press
what's in the news ladies and gentlemen
shall we
admire the highlights
vaccine seems to be on everybody's mind
if not in
everybody's veins quite yet because you
see it's a tiered system
only the elderly are getting the shot
right now
so this joke might not play for those of
you who are awaiting the vaccine
if you're worried that you won't get the
vaccine
this is perhaps a wise worry
it's clearly not enough to go around
so be afraid
be very afraid your government has
betrayed you
so i was reading about the side effects
of some of the covert vaccines because
i'm a reader
it's what i do get up in the morning
take a [ __ ] read google news
that's where i read about the side
effects of the colvin vaccine
and i have to say i don't think getting
the vaccine is a very good idea anymore
what
excuse me why would you
call out the middle of my set
did everybody see that there's just tend
to be no understanding of the basics of
stand-up comedy sir this is not a
dialogue it's a monologue
again with anything but an appreciative
laugh and you will find my hand at your
throat
my empty fist shove down your mouth
breaking it at the sides curbing you
in essence without putting you on the
curb
such as the power of my fist
now shut the [ __ ] up so i could do the
punchline
and the punchline that i paid forty
dollars for
is the fever don't you remember the
setup
i was
i was saying that i was reading about
the side effects of the corporate
vaccines while i was
taking a [ __ ] and beating google news
that i have to say i don't think getting
the vaccine is a very good idea do you
know why
do you know why
doing a lame audience no
oh thank you glad to see one person
showed up for the [ __ ] show
i know we're meant to be socially
distanced but
please there has to be
more than one intelligent being amongst
you and the
25 of capacity crowd i'm working tonight
the voice line in case you didn't
remember i was reading about the side
effects of some of the corvette vaccines
i do this when i take a [ __ ] and read
google news and i have to say i don't
think getting the vaccine is a very good
idea
just kidding i may be a mass homicidal
maniac that blew up a football stadium
and grew up in a hole but i'm not
crazy
okay stop crazy
all right boss i hate it when a comedian
repeats their punchline if they don't
get the laugh they want when they just
repeat it
i think the guy that said that gasped in
the
you know after the first time that he
turned on i think that guy was his chill
because gasping at what he said really
underlines
the flip for the punch line oh so you
think you helped him out
yeah i do i think that guy might
actually know a little bit more about
comedy than you're giving him credit or
that
bane is giving him credit for i can be
honest with you if you're looking for
any [ __ ] sense out of bane
you're paying attention to his movies
he's he don't care
that's true he is what he is uh let's
press play this is shit's
he's on fire man he's on fire he's on
fire here we go and play
the super bowl is this weekend isn't it
a super bowl yay
yes get your chips in your dips
well i prepare to blow up the stadium in
pond which they play this
ball of the foot
but with every super bowl comes two
things
one an opportunity to subjugate gotham
yet again
and do the puppy bowl
i'm gonna rock you with a little puppy
ball humor
one you could bring home and tell your
mother
i was excited for the puppy but my god i
took a
big inhalation of like i was an emcee of
some sort
i must be catching it must be
must be what's the what is the word when
one could catch a disease
contagious it must be contagious you
couldn't think of the word contagious
now i'm wearing a mask and i'm popping
[ __ ]
laughing gas into my lungs at all times
sometimes it's hard to think
you don't know what it's like
to be the pain man
there's lots of pain man
anyway back to the jokes the puppy bowl
is something i'm very excited about
i was all excited for the puppy ball
this year on super bowl sunday until i
found out it was a tv
show and not a take out order
looking forward to watching footballers
play
while i ate a bowl of puppies
anyway i i didn't understand that one
either i did not see the humor
i bet you that's a confusion for a lot
of people
i can't be the only one you don't know
how many times i called up
and i mean i [ __ ] went to postmates
and entered puppy balls
nothing nothing not a single notice they
tell me to support my local eateries but
none of the big puppy balls
make something i want and you'll get my
harder
dollar till then every man
for himself anyway back to the funny
you all remember macaulay culkin correct
he was the child actor who was in the
home
shut up
interrupt my train of thought
now i have to start all over again don't
you understand
comedy is a series of memorized routines
if you break the routine i cannot move
forward i have to go back to the
beginning
the jokes are designed to be interacted
with at the punchline that is
require my concentration to tell the
joke
the joke is out then you
[ __ ] react
remember macaulay coke and now it's
blown everybody
knew what uh now they know where i'm
going with it i can't surprise them i'm
sure they're going to see the home alone
of it all coming
what else are you going to talk about
when you talk about macaulay coconut now
i have to do it twice
everyone pretend i did not say macaulay
culkin
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah bright rich man
speaking of rich man of hollywood
did you know that six men were arrested
for putting fake letters on the
hollywood sign
recently so instead of saying hollywood
the sardines dead red holly boob
which doesn't even rhyme
makes no sense i have a series of punch
lines i can rock you with multiple
choice
it's like that game show who wants to be
a millionaire except you can't call
anybody for help
you're getting all three
first punchline arrested there are
dozens of doctors in beverly hills whose
business
is to put fake boobs on hollywood if
they make a million dollars a year
more
eat the rich
um then
then there's this punchline i wasn't
that impressed the pranksters only
pulled it off
with a set of double bees
they're flat-chested
what in high school they refer to as a
carpeted dream
flat as a board easy to nail
that's how i remember it
pardon me third punch line third choice
i guess not getting arrested was part of
the plan if they wanted a big
bust they got one
do you see must
can mean multiple things and in this
instance it's referring to the barbary
glands you're all so fond of
nipples and babies and such oh
look at the boobies you did grope in a
dark hill hole like i did
i suckled not at the teat but and
horrible things at the end
of corrupted convicted men
use your bachelor's imagination
speaking of imagination how about
macaulay culkin
what an imagination this kid has
am i right anyway
so
speaking of bakari cokin
tina macaulay coconut joined the calls
to have
donald trump's cameo removed from home
alone
too macaulay coke and himself
ladies and gentlemen the boy at the
center of the movie the lost boy
so now the only times you'll see donald
trump home alone and the number two
together
will be on a golden toilet mar-a-lago